staying on theme he is the verified
Santa on Tick Tock with over 4.3 million
followers he goes by the name of Santa J
Claws and is spreading holiday cheer one
video at a time Mercedes talked with
them to learn more
I can't believe he has taken the time so
close to Christmas to talk to us but we
have Santa J claws hello Merry Christmas
hello there my friend hello there how
are you doing today I am doing well but
the bigger question is how are you doing
this is a big time of year for you it is
the final marathon before the deliveries
begin but it's such an exciting time
it's so neat to see you in your element
and I have to tell you Santa J claws I
follow you on Tick Tock and you have
like 4.4 million followers I love seeing
you you just bring a smile to my face
every time how did you decide to join
tick tock
well it was something that I truly felt
within my heart I was seeing all of
these children that were participating
in this tiki-talkie and they were doing
all sorts of wonderful dances and
wonderful things but I also was seeing
that the world was experiencing perhaps
a need and a reminder of kindness and
goodness as well what a wonderful
opportunity to use the what I call the
technological song to be able to spread
a little bit of Christmas cheer
throughout the year I get so excited
when you come visit us here in the
United States of America we always leave
you our cookies and we we wait to hear
the Jingle Bells when you arrive at our
house what are some of the holiday
traditions like in other parts of the
world that you travel
a wonderful wonderful question I think
it's important when when we're thinking
of leaving out milk and cookies where
there are wonderful Traditions
throughout the world some might even
leave out a mince pie or a little piece
of cheese or there some countries that
will leave out a bowl of porridge so
there are all sorts of different ways to
look about the traditions of Christmas a
wonderful thing sometimes there are
gifts that are left in a stocking
sometimes there are gifts left within a
shoe or on the windowsill there are all
sorts of wonderful ways to celebrate the
Traditions I just feel so lucky to be
able to talk to you right before
Christmas before I let you go I was
wondering if you could check some names
on the naughty and nice list for me some
of the hosts of Las Vegas now here
certainly certainly okay well let's
start with um Rocky she is one of our
wonderful co-hosts how is how is Rocky
on list
looks to be good my friend looks to be
good oh that's wonderful how about
Jillian she's so sweet can you find
Jillian in there and had a couple Togo
moments but she's doing well now okay
since you're in the jail
we have two other hosts uh JC since
you're in the Jays how was he this year
Tracy's doing wonderful and who is the
last one my friend okay that is Kendall
I'm a little worried about him
um I'm keeping my fingers crossed
we might need to follow up on this one
am I in there by chance I mean I already
checked on this one my friend and you
have made the list and I thank you for
your kindness as well
you inspire us to be kind every day not
just this time of year Santa j-claude if
you haven't followed him on Tick Tock it
will definitely bring a smile to your
face and thank you so much for joining
us Merry Christmas